puppy school is in session can you do
the Fandango you know we used to eat
fandango's in Liverpool hi I'm Dan a
floor fell from Sicard life of flats to
this is not an easy voice that I'm doing
in the movie
it's kind of from lionel Barrymore who
is the old man and it's a wonderful life
your father nothing but it yeah what's
going on my owner got a new puppy we
actually play around with different
voices for pops I think I was doing Cary
Grant at one point look at all these
puppies we did Al Pacino oh hey old man
you got a puppet and then we we came on
news nobody cares
we find out that he's a gruff guy a
heart of gold I'm like pops cuz comedy
ultimately is sort of aggressive and the
characters I've done in the past are
very aggressive
they're like Hans and Franz your
buttocks are like marshmallows you're
lucky we don't have a campfire yeah so
all my characters say inappropriate
thing so Pop's is right yes probably I
play the character of max a messy let's
say we go for a walk and Max is a very
very high-strung dog you've been so
stressed lately
that you know what he cares too much no
I don't really want to say I'm the star
I mean you have this ensemble cast
Tiffany Haddish Eric Stonestreet and you
are especially Kevin Hart it's no time
like Bell Oh sister it's gonna get way
weirder
once you have Harrison Ford for Gandhi
yeah you're sure no I'm not the star of
the movie
Harrison Ford's in it hallelujah how
much you might like max did you just see
the answer I gave I could not be more
high-strung and nervous half of the time
to guess I'm I'm basically max in human
form but I don't have a behavioral
disorder
yeah I'm fine too
we start fires you know Chloe is a very
independent woman she enjoys a snack or
seven my owner might have given me a
little bit of catnip people often say
that you know cats have attitude whoa
whoa whoa hold on now you gotta learn
how to act like a cat in playing a cat I
have gotten to know the personality a
little more and I think there's someone
you know misunderstood cats land on
their feet you know they're just like
independent and comfortable in their own
fur Chloe you're burning oh I wonder
what other sounds I could make
are you finished she's got a great sense
of humor eat sweet pea what cats eat
birds you're seriously gonna make her
you sweet beat oh no no of course no man
bad dog bad cat dog oh she can't
necessarily laugh at herself but she's
working I play Mel in secret life of
pets - someone's in my litter box Mel is
a little rambunctious a little crazy
right not that smart of a dog you got a
lot of heart though in secret life of
pets too he hasn't gotten any smarter
now get get out of there
he's proudly not smart he's just happy
to be alive if Meryl is is awake he's
got a smile on his face does mal have
any bad qualities I don't think so I
think he is pure goodness out of all the
dogs in the world Mel might be the
sweetest one in the world
my little mouth I love them too all my
heart
[Music]